I know who you are
I got another good one for
we've been all by yourself through this
yeah I want my parents to come home now
and you you keep an eye on that front
door you're our lookout it's Doug you
got it and I'm Carly
okay Carly you'll shift in with Doug you
got it boss and I don't give a [ __ ]
about what happens to you but if
anything happens to my daughter or that
little girl you've got with you you
watch your ass how's Gary look at that
face
welcome back to that stuff going on here
episode 2 of walking dead of course
we're gonna I don't see any reason why
we should wait in between these episode
I hear this is the best one so far out
of the three of them not sure but that
means me I can pick her nose like he's
picking out and so yeah I'm looking
forward to play it hope your brothers
will look forward to see it
Aska also I had to replay the ending
because apparently if you don't sit
through the the credits it doesn't save
your final option whether you save Carly
or Doug and the game shows that I save
dog for whatever reason and I thought
that was kind of stupid so I replay NIT
Thank You game by the way for making me
sit through all the credits and not
being able to skip them and here we go
there's a Miss I got that zambie okay
it's gonna knock that zombie already got
that doesn't work yeah nice going Lee is
that a bunny that poor little thing
hey man hey what'd they get this time
looks like a rabbit so they're eating
all the animal that's another meal how
can Adame get a bunny their fastest okay
Bobby if we went through all that that
makes zero Zen months it seemed like so
much at the time maybe you shouldn't
have open the door yeah except then I'd
probably be food by now trust me I have
no regrets gangmo rabbits hardly a meal
market bag ticket meeting over Mike in
that County did sorry vegetarians last
night I heard your friend Doug laying in
bed just naming types of pie he's
driving me nuts [ __ ] dying he's starting
to lose it he's not the only one
I mean got him some slack yeah you're
right
I wish I knew for sure how much food we
ever left not an hour enough according
to Lily we've just about hit the last of
our food reserves saying people might
have to go without tonight no Nina
Lily's lottery again Kenny's gonna be
pissed she thinks everyone should have
an equal chance of missing a leaf you
think Kenny's having any more luck than
we are out here
I sure hope so yeah between the lack of
food and Kenny and Lily fighting all the
time things are getting pretty tense
back at the motor in the [ __ ] are you
anyway talking about taking off if he
can get that RV running
it's got a family with a gasolin to look
out for uh-huh their safest in a big
group going out on his own we'll get
them all killed
can't blame him though did you hear
Larry going off on him last night
we'll see old guys deal anyway seems
like he's got a problem with you in
particular well they think I'm dangerous
I'm a danger to the group hey Clementine
I think he's the one putting us in
danger the way Lilly worries about his
health I wouldn't be surprised if she
said skimming rations for him and I know
Lilly thinks he's getting weaker but the
guys on muscle he's a walking pile
driver I know I wouldn't want to be
stuck in a room with him
and didn't he punch you in the face one
time knock me flat that son of a [ __ ]
I'll never forget it this is it uh can I
put on subtitles
what's up Raven are you gonna shoot the
bird you're gonna waste a bullet for a
bird that is don't risk a noise can you
make this shot I'm sure I need to waste
the bullets trust me if I don't think I
can hit it
I won't shoot all right well then [ __ ]
yeah wha [ __ ] with that Kenny I don't
know come on why would they scream now
why Kenny
nah
[Music]
it's weird how this setting and
everything is different where did he get
that jacket it looks so handsome that I
mean I want his jacket I hope he dies I
can take it wow guys what's going on
ouch brow jeez how did he walk in that
riot doesn't [ __ ] we just want to
help our teacher will leave I swear okay
okay you need to Scott screaming calm
there to help these might be the same
guys that raided our camp and we barely
got away from that what guys here I
don't know man
who read it again I don't know guys with
guns huh we won't bother you I swear
this [ __ ] up gotta help please my dad
was Special Forces I know what I'm doing
head him out after that you can leave us
or whatever I don't care
please uh let's try it or get him out of
there oh God thank you fine but you
gotta hurry
wait then they kill zombies with that
axe she need me infected then first I
took him long enough
Oh
behind you come on gotta move I know
Travis good this run seriously
come on you deserve how the hell did he
make it this far they just want to hug
you
they really get right into it that's
quite then Chuck I didn't expect that
holy [ __ ] that was disgusting ah dude
poor men
episodes here starved for death knifes
hammer Deborah
seriously
that's pretty good for it Merrill's nice
going Clementine that's right I love ya
what do you want duck nice going
Clementine you rockin that keep punching
those baths she looks like [ __ ]
[Music]
Oh who's that michael calling this
clam 8 can you stop that for one second
what it what I have get the gates open
we've got wounded [ __ ] how are they
doing gates and stuff
I don't have time to explain get him
into the truck I'm sorry she cares about
I don't know me well you can't just be
bringing new people here what are you
thinking hey you want to calm down for a
[ __ ] why don't all this [ __ ] you know
what you thought bringing more mouths to
feed was a good idea Jesus you would
have died you would have died if we left
him so what we are not responsible for
every struggling survivor we come across
we have to focus on our group right here
right now come on Lily these are people
people trying to survive just like us
yeah got to stick together to say god
help each other the only reason you're
here is because you had food enough for
all of us but that food is almost gone
we've got maybe a week's worth left and
I don't suppose you guys are carrying
any groceries are you yeah it's been
autumn no fine you guys fight it out
there
welcome to the family kid
come over here and see what I drew what
no what come on well you let me think
you're the leader of this little group
but we can make our own goddamn
decisions
this isn't your own personal
dictatorship that's right
hey I didn't ask to leave this group
everyone was happy to have me
distributed ugly enough to go around but
now that it's running out suddenly I'm a
goddamn Nazi well he's right this group
needs someone to be a leader oh no I
didn't want to side with Lilly oh come
on I'm [ __ ] ourselves great way to
take sides Lee I'm sorry Kenny hey hey
I'm sorry they're here now can't change
that what do you want to do they can
stains how kaca finishes working on that
guy then they have to go all the [ __ ]
don't care what condition they're in
why don't have enough food
well what the [ __ ] see any of you
stepping up to make the hard decisions
my girls got more balls than all of you
combined that is this a nasty why don't
you go help mark with the wall why don't
you just [ __ ] off
that's right why are you alive I can't
do this right now you understand what
I'm dealing with
please do me a favor I need you to
handle the Russians today
why don't you give it out if we're gonna
make what's left lasts a week then this
is all we can spare today bang it's not
gonna be enough for everyone but just do
what you think is
so I'm handing out these
[Music]
oh I gotta get up to Kenny I'm sorry I
decided with that [ __ ] food items for
ten hungry people all right I got to
make sure the kids get some
but now that [ __ ] duck
[Music]
oh this is depressing
[Music]
goddamnit
all right climate your first in my list
how you doing
where's you
can you help me find it I'll help you
find it a couple days ago I promise if I
find of cars climbing okay Claire I've
got to take care of some things don't
you go back to playing with duck for a
while okay I claim a here you go that's
for being awesome here Claire you need
something to eat I guess an apple I love
apples
I know that yeah well complain no sorry
there was a last 100 enjoy it you
deserve it
you rock Plan B that [ __ ] you doc all
right I'm sorry Kenny I'm really an all
right want something to eat
here Kenny take this how about my boy he
eat yet No
come talk to me once my boys taken care
of come on well I guess I gotta give
that piece of [ __ ] a little bit of food
not what do you want hey Doc how about a
little food oh come on that's [ __ ]
face
all right what do you want I just want
to punch you what do you want piece of
jerky yeah oh man I'm so hungry
alright you better appreciate that and
then I'll get one too yeah
that's that want something to eat here
Kenny take this take about my boy he yet
yeah something don't worry I riding and
hand it over
I'm starved Thanks oh [ __ ] the other one
noticed the only one left huh
now on us some of these people have gone
longer than me without food they're the
ones eat it yeah but I don't know who
should I give it to what am I going so
awkward
well not you because you're new I don't
see a reason why I should give you and
maybe
no I already she she has a lot of fat
pack in there I think she'll do just
fine
what do we got on here it's dirty but
it's not gonna hold up forever just like
the rest of this place
holy [ __ ] how they fixed the front porch
what about yeah I don't want to really
give to you Annie you're supposed to be
that hold the damn board steady I'm
trying I I didn't realize I was getting
this week already
what do you want a handout oh I got 60
cents in my pocket if you're shut up and
quit being such a pansy you're in the
patency
all right I'm gonna give it right in
front of him hey fat man look at that
here eat something give cracker and
cheese man Simon Rowley need any help
with the wall nope
actually we could use your axe you mind
if we take it yeah give us that thing
for a bit I don't like this give axe who
is which I wish I know their names
Peter Burke this should help Thanks I
think I'm the one doing all the work
over here
yeah but you're also the [ __ ]
loudmouth piece of [ __ ] come on Larry
give it a rest I'm Shirley is getting
pretty sick of you thinking he's a
danger to the group is that what you
told him yeah that's not what I meant
yeah that's right that's right and
that's why I'm gonna do a buck I gotta
chop your balls off my lips but you two
have got to start trying to get along
the only thing I have to canvass protect
my daughter gun test now that means
getting this damn wall fixed so I would
appreciate it if you two would shut up
and let me get back to work all right
fine geez he's the one talking
I thought I had to deal with that Larry
or mark whatever your name is
hey don't cry ah she didn't get anything
not such an easy job is it I don't envy
you I don't know how you have the
strength to do this every day
I don't have a choice well you look like
a pig
thanks for looking out for me and my
family don't worry buddy
and it's still I guess some people
aren't gonna be happy with your choices
don't you shout what happened to my food
there's none left
you're fighting I'm fighting people like
this and your days in this group are
numbered you're one to talk old man
yeah well I don't see you working on
that wall that's the point actually it's
a good point son of a [ __ ]
come here please he didn't make it did
he he lost too much blood
damn it I'm getting sick of this [ __ ]
can come back there's nothing no capture
but he just needs time enough morning
that man you brought I tried but he was
never going to survive well at least
he's not our problem anymore
isn't he gonna tell his friends holy
[ __ ] no that's gonna [ __ ] to me dude
[Applause]
oh-oh-oh
get him harder oh no my buddy you don't
use that right man I gotta protect cabin
time oh oh go back
oh yeah stay away from me wow it really
wants my [ __ ]
Oh
oh man that's gross
that is nasty a spy he got infected from
your hacks I do Braga we got to watch
each other's backs right right jump
bring him here in the first place
[ __ ] dad calm down
you're gonna get us all killed oh I
cares about what happened he was bitten
what he was bitten and you didn't see a
gun to him Wirt but he wasn't bitten I
swear
well you're not bitten friend here came
back to life and tried to kill my wife
what wait you all don't know what I'm
talking about
we're all in fact then not the bite that
does it it's no you come back no matter
how you die if you don't destroy the
brain that's just what happens it's
gonna happen to all of us
you're lying you're lying it's true
I swear it maybe he's right I didn't see
any bite it would explain why there's so
many of them Jesus Christ you just die
and that's all it takes and [ __ ] one
fatal car wreck and a family of five
turns into a family of walkers when I
first saw it happen we were all hiding
out in a gym and everybody thought we
were finally safe but one of the girls
Jenny picture I think I guess she
couldn't take it she took some pills a
lot of them Jenny picture someone went
in the girls room the next morning and
God all right I'm gonna end this episode
here breath damn that's a good episode
hope you guys enjoy I'm definitely
looking forward to playing more of this
if you are new i really suggest checking
out episode 1 because there's a lot of
epicness going on there anyway soccer
favorite if you enjoyed subscribe rate
today and i'll see you next time honey
that's a mess
[Music]
but we're gonna stop there we go there
we go I think I got it
whooping gum